that's actually my favorite part about
that story that isn't in the story if
you're married one of the true gems
about being married is to be able to
bother your spouse
where are they going you know what I
mean they they just have to grin and
bear it so I love bothering Beth I love
doing things that are going to upset her
and I was like this is really going to
bum her out
so I'm gonna have to show her this
picture
it's so cruel we were in bed and when I
saw it and so
right away my first reaction was oh no
and then I was like oh yeah
so I just started laughing I was like
this is so funny she was like what I go
ahead it's you won't think it's funny
she's like show me I'm like you sure
and I go here it is she goes oh no
just a straight trap it's so great yeah